okay explain the [__] Edge what the
[__] is this come on okay um obviously
obviously it was my introduction to
realize that's crustless pizza it's
Pizza Hut Pizza Hut okay I will
say I Pizza Hut no no do not defend
Pizza wait wait wait wait what are you
saying to to completely just disregard
my previous argument about McDonald's
and like childhood memories and all that
[__] Pizza heart just has this certain
smell no no other Pizza Joint can like
yeah it has the smell of like day old
kitchen grease that's that's what I love
it when my my my pizza I can break it
over my leg no no no no no no like you
know how Subway has that smell like
whenever you walk it's it's such like
ionic smell no it's not iconic sorry
it's not it's not it is when you go
there but like smells well smells way
better than it tastes right sure to me
like to me no other Pizza Joint like the
kind of like mainstream pizza joint no
other mainstream Pizza Joint has that
unique smell except for pizza heart I
don't know what it is but all of them
have their own unique smell see I don't
understand this because I think I was
one of those weird kids who never got
like chain pizzas like I never like my
parents never order from like pizza
domino like my dad made pizzas every
Frid we never got them so like I don't
know this like I don't have any like
Nostalgia with like pizza hudle Dom okay
I did because like uh you know when when
I was growing up at broke kid
uh like they I can't remember what day
it was but one day of the week they
would do like all you can eat pizzas
Pizza Hut that was that was like my
pizza intake for the month a UK thing I
went as well that's crazy I did like
that a lot and and that's how I got
Pizza Hut pilled and then I grew up and
I was like wait this is the worst this
is the worst of all the pizza CH what's
the best one in the UK some people say
Papa John's I think Domino's in the UK
is really good right I think I think
they're already good I'm not really like
to
me sometimes like like I I think taste
wise I prefer Papa John's but sometimes
I just get that craving for a pizza I
get that craving for just that the whiff
of that smell whatever that Pizza Hut
smell is man all pizzas the [__]
Pizza Hut Edge is in your top nine yes
it is I dream about this [__] man you
know why it's unobtainable anymore
because you can make
this it's cling your judgment because
it's unavailable you think it's better
than it was this is [__] it's [__] I
because we we there are pizzas that are
like this that you know are available
which is kind of like the cross pizzas
but I I've been searching every time I I
look for I'm in America I see this kind
of pizza and I'm like this is going to
be the one this is going to be the one
that gives me back the memories again
this is going to be really Rel my
childhood but it's missing that smell
it's missing that pizza hot smell of
just whatever that Pizza Hut spell I'm
pretty sure they just you know sprinkle
this with like happiness and okay well
that's not true true an angel dust or
the sadness of underpaid
star interpretation that must be what it
is Pizza in recent years is just a sad
shell of what it was and even when it
was at its peak it wasn't very good
either yeah pizart fell off um just not
did it fall off yeah I think it might
off in the US especially do you know why
it fell off because they got rid of this
off their menu once they bring the edge
back back to West here baby bring back
the cold classic yeah off cuz it
[__] I mean like to me obviously I'm
going to enjoy a crustless pizza but um
also just okay so so are you saying the
only difference between this Pizza Hut
Edge and every other cross pizza is that
every other cross Pizza is not made by
Pizza Hut is that what you're saying
pretty much also also what I can't
fathom is that we had this whole big
[__] deal about how I said American
Pizza was better than Italian pizza and
here you are putting a [__] American
style pizza on your 9x9 best foods of
all time when you looked me in the face
and lied to me about saying that the
other style of pizza was Superior I mean
how do you apologize hasn't come around
how do you apologize for the Italians
look look look I am putting something on
here that is like to me if they brought
this back I will happily admit that
American but it's not obtainable anymore
okay it lives off in the dreams of my
childhood okay it's like waiting for the
second coming of Christ you like Happ
one day you were like Preposterous how
could he even consider American Pizza be
better than the superior it'll one day
and when that day comes I will be a
believer
again leg are paper thin G the Bible
could drop a sequel and I'd be and pizza
could drop the edge like a rerun of the
edge and I'd be like all right all right
Bible two two all right Italians do you
hear this this man didn't care about
your pizza he wanted something better
this entire time he was hoping the
Americans would swoop in and save the
day I still stand by don't worry please
just just re-release the edge please you
I thought you going to be like P please
sponsor us what what just give me back
you know I don't need like I know it
kind of recently had a rerun in America
and I was dumb enough to not fly to
America to just relive that dream and I
regret that every moment of my life okay
but hypothetical if you did right
hypothetically you flew back hearing
about the Edge 2 coming back right the
edge the eding uh you know you hear that
it came back and you buy it all right
and you're expecting all the Nostalgia
to flow back what if it's not the same
it will be the same but what if it's not
uh what if there's just something about
the the recent Pizza heart as opposed to
your childhood and what if the Earth is
flat Joey it's not why you ask
me why you ask me a hypo hypothetical
question would you still love it huh
would you still love it yeah of course
of course you're full Co mode dude I
can't believe you're I have no doubt
that I will love this
the absolutely not but there's no way to
prove it because they're never going to
bring it back until they do until they
do and then hey if if trash taste fans
put enough PE pressure on
pizza if they do I would actually like
just fly to America I I look for like
a bring back the edge yeah I would look
for an excuse to visit like Sid's family
and it'll be like okay but the real
reason I'm here
is you just Mom Dad take me to Pizza H
right now isn't it um which style of
pizza is it where Square
um Chicago style pizza is no that's yeah
Chicago square one no it's Detroit right
am I crazy Chicago chicag yeah they have
the square one where the middle yeah the
middle pieces are like Edge yes the edge
there's no no cross it's just the middle
no no no but you don't understand it's
not made by Pizza it's not made by pizza
oh my God that's the whole point we're
getting at that's why this is stupid
this is so [__] dumb this is dumb
your your L is
dumb all right uh chocolate and egg form
chocolate yeah chocolate egg form
explain this what the [__] I kind of
understand you're coming from I hate to
admit I kind of get where you're coming
from with this I don't know why explain
it to me okay so sometimes a chocolate
bar is way too [__] much I just I
just just like a chocolate and buff do I
relate to this you know what I mean like
a chocolate and buff and like here's the
thing it has to be a hollow egg I've had
like completely solid chocolate egg
where the [__] have you gotten solid
eggs from oh they make like the kind of
the smaller
ones you get that [__] s that's like
half the global chocolate Supply that
was not I know I like to me an egg is
just the best way to present chocolate I
don't like there's just something that's
just I just have really good memories of
Easter time yeah right you know think
all I can think about is a [__] Tik
Tok with that sculpting chocolate guy
where he makes like the [__] and then he
sculpts it into like a bird but it's
like a full-on dick for like one part
you know I'm talking about yeah I know
exactly what you're talking about P you
show chocolate [__] sculpture the the
Tik Tock guy I don't know what I don't
know what the I it's always like
whenever you scul something it's always
like [__] shaped until it's nuts it just
starts off
like oh wait it's an eagle oh yeah of
course of course I knew it's an eagle
what is this penis
l no work made of chocolate yeah you got
a one more uh maybe click that Reddit
one uh
yeah yeah [__] guys it's always the
[__] guy yeah this is the one this is
the one that looks like a dick look at
this
one wait wait let me see check this out
yeah okay so yeah
okay oh my God knew exactly what he was
doing
making KN I knew there was a snake I
knew it was a snake the entire time I
knew it was a snake too yeah that makes
sense holy [__] that's impressive I
would have know better if it was a [__]
it was a massive [__] if it was actually
[__] anyway back back to the sorry this
is just what my bra distracted by
chocolate [__] any right all right oh
this is a dragon I thought this was
going to be the eagle um yeah uh sorry
penis [__] uh that's penis [__] um I was
I was like you mean like I was like
trying I was like trying to oh yes so so
you're saying everything is better in
egg form now explain your logic for that
cuz I don't understand this this notion
okay so like I it's like when it's in
egg form it's just the perfect thick
okay it's it's sometimes you bite into
like a chocolate bar and it's just too
[__] much it's just like way too hard
it's too much chocolate to chew for to
chew through but with like what are you
[__] 90 with Dentures what are you
talking about but with like it's like
it's too it's too much sweetness all at
once right it's too much chocolate with
like a chocolate egg you can just break
it off and it's just like break it off
it's nice little bite-sized it's like e
potato chips you know yeah yeah yeah
it's like the perfect size and shape and
thinness you know you can get like
little little bags right of like mini
chocolates so you can have like little
like bite-sized chocolates no no no no
no but that's still too thick it needs
to be like like it needs to be like it's
the idea that you can just break it off
like that yes it's like just nice and
thin and you can just break it off like
a bigger piece and it's just it's just
so much more fun also makes the best
noises when you into like a lot of
chocolate bar there are a lot of thin
chocolate bars out there um that exist
they're not egg shaped they're not EG
shaped they're not egg shaped like it
doesn't the [__] is the egg shap also
it's that childhood en Joy when you got
one of those massive ones during the
Easter and you just like can I break it
can I smash it and then doing that still
fun as an adult [__] you smash it wait
wait how how do you eat an Easter egg
well like like a regular siiz Easter egg
yeah okay so you you get like a large
Easter egg right like like how big are
we talking uh like kind of like kind of
kind of like you know kind of like this
size where it's not like bite size but
it's like one of one of like the larger
ones at the supermarket okay do you do
you take like a first bite or do you
break it oh I break it you break it do
you smash the whole thing oh yeah that
was my favorite thing dude when I was a
kid I used to give my sister to hold the
egg as I'd [__] like punch it in like
that and that was the most fun that was
the most fun thing you're Barbarian so
fun you were meant to like make a little
indent and slowly chip away at it no
what's the fun in that because it keeps
the form of the egg it doesn't matter
I'm going to eat it all in a day yeah
but then you can B you can snap it into
sizes that are preferable instead of
having crumbs everywhere cuz the worst
part of the egg which is why I don't I
don't agree with this take is that more
often than not it just ends up like
crumbling or little [__] crumble
pieces in the egg I [__] love though
because because you know then can
[__] oh I'd love I'd love my
microscopic bites of chocolate oh it's
great it's it's like great it's like
micro doing on chocolate yeah yeah yeah
yeah because because like when you get
to the end of the egg you have like this
little pile of like chocolate crumbs and
you're just
like what the [__] I hate that I I'm
totally on with all of a Twist I don't
want [__] crumbs of chocolate I'm
totally it's it's like a little extra
it's it's similar to like I guess it's
the equivalent of cleaning off the
potato chip bag exactly that's it that's
that's the best part yeah I don't know
like this is just to me the best way to
present chocolates if I could just go
without a chocolate bar and just be sold
chocolate Easter eggs all year round I
would buy the Easter egg kind what kind
of chocolate are we talking about are we
just talking like Dairy chocolate white
chocolate dark chocolate what's your
favorite I mean I'm I'm like a basic
[__] I just just give me like dairy
milk chocolate da milk what um I prefer
dark chocolate I I prefer dark chocolate
I like white chocolate it's not
chocolate technically but I do like it a
lot but to me like to me to me white
chocolate and dark chocolate like
they're they're completely different
things to me right to me okay this just
contral to whom okay no no they I guess
how can how can I yeah I was going to
say cuz you're saying it like they are
different things that's crazy like yeah
yeah uh they inhabit different moods
that like I I crave them but
it's only in like certain situations
dark chocolate I want to have at the end
of the meal maybe a coffee I don't want
to I never want to have a ton of
chocolate though I just don't ever want
to eat a full yeah to me I can have like
milk chocolate anytime any mood I've had
a toone in my fridge for the past year
and I've I every month I take a see
that's the problem with toor I [__]
love toburen they're too thick uh yeah
yeah they are well I mean if we had
tooren in egg form I destroy that in
holy [__] you're so right Joey I would
destroy in a day if it's in egg form
turone all day long where are they yeah
the the whole point of the to but the
chocolate itself is so Banger if we had
that exact same flavor I'm going to blow
your mind in egg form it's Banger cuz
it's thick and they can fit a lot of
little [__] in there no no no no no
there's there's enough thickness in the
eggs there's no there's not you just
were saying how they need to be thin so
now let's which one we not talking like
paper thin we're talking like not a
[__] full it's always like the
perfect thickness you know it's the
perfect thickness chocolate which is not
like paper thin you know there's still
some texture to it there's still you
know you still get like the chocolate
enough chocolate flavor but it's just
not overwhelming you know it's chocolate
eggs best way to present chocolate